I don't know I guess I also do a lot of
uh I'm seeing okay yeah a lot of events
not good at public speaking though so
it's okay nor am I and I don't know how
I found myself in this job either
because I've always been [__] of public
speaking until uh kind of like trial by
fire you put they put you on the stage
and you're like I don't know what I'm
doing but I'm just going to pretend and
wait but that makes more sense for you
because you're a YouTuber all right
Clayton you're an idol yeah like isn't
isn't the main job to be on stage I'm an
idol by mistake though okay
how do you become an idol by mistake
yeah how did that happen so I came to
Japan
um to become a voice actor and I
couldn't really read um that much
Japanese so for the
auditioning I didn't really read like
the information but I saw characters so
I was like okay so it's a voice acting
crew right and then I got in and then
they were like well you're gonna be an
idol too I'm like oh okay and then
you've got babysitter
you basically went for a job interview
and you're like I don't know what the
job is but yeah I see a cute anime girl
so I'm gonna fight it
known though because by the third round
like usually in voice acting auditions
people would be doing like vocal
warm-ups yeah everybody was fixing their
makeup so I'm like I should like that's
one I should have known
yeah there was a dancing part too and
I'm like I don't know why you guys need
to see me dance
I'm like okay weird but okay
let me go even further back that's okay
so why did you originally grow up and
then how did that how did that go from
because there's a big leap to be like I
want to go to Japan and be a voice actor
it's like that's a huge thing oh yeah um
I was born and raised in Los Angeles all
my life up until like seven years ago
okay
right right and
um I wasn't really into anime when I was
really young you know right but uh in
middle school I met Gintama
oh
and like before then
um I went to like a school where there
weren't many Asian people around me so
like this is a really bad thing to say
but I was kind of ashamed of being
Japanese you know I was like why am I
not like the other people you know like
bringing you know it's like really
typical story but you know you bring
your Japanese school lunch and
everybody's like ew what is that you
know I feel that yeah yeah so I was like
why am I not like other girls and like
you know I pretended like I couldn't
speak Japanese in front of my parents oh
wow so yeah I was like shutting every
Japanese aspect in my life like out but
I met Gintama and yeah Gintama and I got
into the anime culture and it finally
made me like really like who I was you
know like embrace the Japanese side
right yeah culture yeah it's insane that
you say that because you know you're
saying you grew up in La which is now
like if I would think of a that is like
the biggest cultural Melting Pot I've
been to in the world it's probably La
you know L.A is so many different
cultures and you know has it changed
over like the years where you've grown
up in La where now
it's like more accepted to be every kind
of like different culture and ethnicity
I heard with um covid and everything
like uh anime became pretty mainstream
and very very popular so yeah definitely
had an explosion of the coverage I think
like it changed a bit in that way yeah
because I actually like I think I went
through something similar because I grew
up in Brighton and I was also I think
like the only Asian kid in my school the
same yeah same same for you as well yeah
and now like Brighton is like the super
Progressive City with so many like
different cultures and I look at my city
now and I'm like I do not recognize the
city that I grew up in that yeah what
was like because you know you're from La
what was like little Toca like when you
were growing I was like was that even
like a thing at all it was a thing while
I was there
um you know people would have a little
Meetup with their cosplay community and
stuff I was there too oh hell yeah
dressing up as like attacking things
nice
yeah and then like we would be all
bloody and people would give us weird
scares me like why are there bloody
teenagers they're just like holding the
cops I think there's been a crime
because you guys have been in Japan for
around the same time right seven years
yeah I moved about seven years ago as
well oh yeah yeah back in like 2016 yeah
so I feel like we and weirdly enough
like you know with you it's America but
for me it's Australia like I feel like
we it sounds like we had very similar
kind of upbringings in that sense
because like I also had like a period as
well where like you know because being
half Japanese and a predominantly you
know white country like Australia even
with all of like the different
nationalities and everything I
definitely felt like a bit of like a
weird cultural identity crisis almost
where it's like I was the only Asian kid
in my school I got bullied for it uh to
an extent and so I was kind of like not
ashamed but I guess like I wasn't like
upfront as much yeah right about like
being Japanese which like I think you
know my mom didn't really take that all
too well you know she was like no you
should be proud to be Japanese you know
and everything like that and I don't
think for me it was Gintama but it was
like it was something else I'm some
other anime but yeah was a great choice
which is which is insane because you
know when we went to visit Sydney I was
like oh that's a lot of Asian people
there's so many Asians
like Sydney especially because I think
it's like the biggest Japanese like uh
like group in all of Australia as well
there's a huge Japanese community in
Australia now
um but I feel yeah that definitely
changed over time I don't know what it
was maybe it was okay here's a big test
right was it easy for you guys to find
like good Japanese food when you were
like growing up in LA or Australia
um because uh now you know now us
visiting there I think it's pretty easy
to find good Japanese food especially in
L.A was it like the same way when you
guys were growing up well um because my
parents were born and raised in Japan
right we wouldn't really go out to eat
Japanese food I know what that was like
yeah we have the benefit of having
Japanese
I guess that makes sense right yeah I
was going for like a roast dinner yeah
no no it's like the same yeah it's like
the like same for me as well except like
you know if I wanted to show my friends
like Thai food they'd be like oh is
there I don't think like Thai food
restaurants was like even really a
concept because we got like one Thai
restaurant that I knew of and it was
mine or it was like my parents so yeah
but you're gonna use that as the hook
right like to your friends with me like
I know this bomb ass Thai place and they
just invite them to your house yeah if
you've never told that story you could
just lie down and this is the best Thai
restaurant yeah yeah yeah that was back
in the day when you know you take your
friends to try a new Cuisine and like
what do you mean you eat rice with
everything like you fancy [__]
what is that okay so I want to ask
questions
why was it Gintama that God you want to
anime well um it was just a moment in my
life where I was just like hitting rock
bottom yeah and
um you know it was just a moment in my
life when I wasn't really laughing at
anything and I was in my room skipping a
lot of like school days and stuff just
because I didn't want to go to school
and I was on Tumblr and this like Google
like just came around and I was like
what is this like like it was like a
really stupid joke that was like really
funny you know and I feel like that kind
of joke was something that I needed in
my life you know like something I can
kind of laugh at like being like like
what is this you know I started watching
it and then I started listening to
sugita tomokazasan's radio yeah and I uh
found out like that you could pursue a
career in voice acting and that's where
it kind of got me but you were just like
[__] I'm going to Japan yeah I'm just
gonna figure it out yeah well um before
I came to Japan
um my cousin's friend who lived in Japan
also wanted to become a voice actor and
so we went to a voice acting school over
the summer for like one day like a trial
day and I thought you could only pursue
voice acting as an adult because every
single time I would search like
Wikipedia for a voice actor's name
they'd be like oh I started at 18 or I
started after college so I thought it
was like an adult thing but when I went
to the voice acting school in Japan like
the girls in that class were like
all right
oh sorry about that so when I went to
the voice acting school in Japan the
girls in that class were like 16 17.
they were like my age so I was like
you could be that young and like start
and you know I felt kind of rushed I was
like I'm already you know Behind These
Girls so I need to go
now I'm already late
so yeah so like what was that like a
specific point where you were like okay
I really really want to pursue voice I
think or was it just kind of like hey
this seems like kind of like a thing a
fun thing I can try to pursue yeah was
it something you always wanted to do as
like a a child yeah from a young age oh
no it was I basically never really had a
dream
um like it's I don't want to make this a
really dark story
please yeah you know when you're just
experiencing something like really bad
if when you
know that there is an end to it like it
just you know gets better like if you
have the class presentation you're like
it's okay it'll be over in like an hour
so yeah you know my nerves will be over
Associated for a while yeah so like
somewhere in middle school I was like
you know what my life is going to end at
18. I was like I just I just you know I
was like this whatever I'm feeling right
now like it's okay like I'm gonna it's
all gonna be over by 18. so I'm just you
know gonna live until 18 and then I
never really had a dream or anything but
I met anime and when I was like 15. I
was like oh maybe like voice acting is
something that I want to do and you know
it really made me a better like anime
really made me into a more happy and
like better person so like I kind of
want to be somebody that can do that for
people who are struggling as well so it
was the one and only dream like still to
this day that I have so much
yeah you know everybody's like what's
the meaning of life you know like why
are we living my meaning of life is like
well you know I still haven't seen the
last episode of One Piece or like you
know the manga that I started reading
like I haven't it's not done yet so yeah
I gotta live until then
that's that's an awesome story because I
guess like I mean I mean
in the period I was growing up in the
like on the Internet it's like it was
almost like frowned upon to be like yo
anime is like important to me and has
done something important to me but I
think for like a lot of people out there
even though even if they don't like want
to admit it it I mean for me personally
it's played like a huge influence my
life and has definitely like helped me
through some tough times as well
um so I think you know that's an awesome
and inspiring story for like a lot of
people to hear that it's not [__] you
know it it is uh it is just fiction but
it can have a real tangible real life
effect on people definitely yeah it
makes me curious though because you you
talked about your childhood and like you
kind of like
kind of always like pushed away the
Japanese side of you to kind of like fit
in better how like how much were you in
touch with your Japanese side when it
was like not around friends when you
were just like at home with your parents
um I would talk like half in English and
half in Japanese and I would always call
my grandma we have a really good
relationship with my grandma so that
those were the only times I usually
spoke in Japanese like my brother and I
would always speak in English so um
still to this day my brother has like an
American accent when he speaks in
Japanese right so it wasn't all that
much it was like 20 of my okay it was
Japanese yeah right was it was it kind
of hard to adjust and then be like all
right now everything's gonna be Japanese
and I could fully change everything my
lifestyle when I first came here
especially because well you know my
parents are Japanese so I look Japanese
so people expect me to speak perfect
Japanese all right but I'm here with
like kind of broken Japanese
you guys are in like a very similar yet
opposite situation because Joey is
obviously very very very good at
Japanese yeah obviously hafu so I think
you both have very like interesting
parallel stories yeah definitely yeah
there's a lot of aspects of your story
that I very much relate to
um but almost in like yeah it's kind of
said like in almost like an opposite
perspective or I guess like an opposite
upbringing almost